رحله علم ملهمه بطلتها سيده حاربت المرض
والاميه معا حققت حلمها بمناقشه رساله
الماجستير بعد ان تمت الثمانين عاما امال
اسماعيل وقفت في محطات عده منذ زواجها
وانشغالها بتربيه اب
نائها اصابتها بمرض السرطان مرتين لكن
تيته امال ضربت لنا مثالا على الاصرار فلم
تنشغل بالتعليقات السلبيه واكملت مشوارها
بين الصفوف الطلاب الذين في اعمار احفادها
طلاب جمعتهم معها علاقه طيبه يساعدونها
ويطمئنون عليها ان غابت عن المدرجات وهي
الان لم تقف هنا بل تستعد لاستكمال
المسيره وتحضير رساله الدكتوراه
[موسيقى]
على كل تنضم الينا من القاهره الحاجه امال
اسماعيل تتامل يسعد صباحك اهلا بك نورتنا
في صباح العربيه
اهلا يا صباح الهنا صباح هنا صباح الحب
تيته امال يعني اولا نبدا بشعورك كيف كان
شعورك بعد ان حصلتي على رساله الماجستير
بعد هذا المشوار الطويل الف مبارك بتقدير
امتياز كمان
الحمد لله هذا من فضل ربي وبعدين ما تنسوش
ان انا هو ما اضفليش جديد لان اصلا ده حلم
نايم جوه قلبي من زمان من وانا طفله فهو
كل الموضوع انك كانك جبت طفل خرجتين من
السرير طلعتي شوفيه وتبوسيه وتحبيه يا
تيته اعمال يعني احنا عايزين نقول لك الف
الف مبروك كمان ومنورانا في الصباح في
صباح العربيه على شاشه العربيه هذا اولا
انتوا اللي منورين هنا والله انتم منورني
انا كمان تسلمي طيب كمان شغله يعني على 38
انت خلصتي مدرسه لا خلصتي اعداديه يعني
خلاص صارلك قعدت سنين ما تعلمتي طب بهذول
السنين شو كان شو راح عليك فيهم ليه اخذتك
لل80 لتكم ابدا زي اي ست بيت عاديه تطبخ
لعيالها تذاكر لهم تعمل لهم لاكثر ولا اقل
يعني
ركزتي على البيت يعني والاولاد
ايوه ايوه ما هو كان ده شرط زوج ان انا ما
اخرجش بره البيت عشان
اسيب الاولاد واروح اتعلم طيب بعد اذنك
عشان تتعلمي
طيب امال بعد رحله قلت انها استغرقت ثلاث
سنين مليئه بالصعوبات نجحتي في مناقشه
رساله الماجستير وبتفوق شو ابرز الصعوبات
اللي واجهتك تتعمل
اذا في عندي صعوبات واجهتني
ان انا مرضت بالكورونا جت قعدتنا سنه ما
كناش بنروح الكليه ولا نتحرك زائد ان انا
اصبت بكسر في الحوض
في السنه التمهيدي للماجستير
فقعدت ست شهور زائد سنه يبقى سنه وست شهور
من ثلاث سنين يعني يعتبر ان انا خلصته في
وقت قياسي يعني اكيد يعني هو بامتياز طب
يا تيته امال كل واحد بالحياه عنده
اهتمامات توجهات انت ليه اخترتي كليه
الاداب بالذات
علشان كنت بحبها لان منها نجب محفوظ الله
يرحمه طه حسين نجيب محفوظ برضو الله يرحمه
امين السعيد سهير القلماوي يعني يوسف
ادريس كان طبيب بس انا كنت بحبك كتابته
يعني يعني معظم اللي بحبهم خريجي كليه
اداب
طيب تيته امال حفيدتك سعادتك في رساله
الماجستير واختارت معك موضوع الرساله كيف
شفتي تشجيع احفادك
دي مش حفيدتي دي مجازا هي استاذتي لكنها
انا بقول حفيدتي عشان فارق السن بيني
وبينه لكن هي استاذتى
من سنه اولى لغايه ما اخذت الماجستير
طيب يا تيته امال ويشرفني طبعا انها كانت
تبقى حفيدتي وتيته امل اكيد احفادك يا
فخورين فيك يا احفادك العشره وحتى اولادك
بس كمان بنتك شاعره يعني كانت عامل مهم
انه تحمسك على الماجستير وتكملي كمان
ايوه لانها هي كانت السبب هي عارفه ان اصل
والدها كان بيني وبينه قصه حب كبيره قوي
وهو توفى سنه 2007
فضلت اربع سنين كده يعني
تعبانه هي حصه ان انا ايه مش قادره انساه
فقالت بقى ايه يعني في قراره نفسه اقول
لماما بقى حاجه عشان
تبطل الاكتئاب والتعب اللي هي فيه ده فكنت
عندها بزورها قالت لي ماما قالت ايوه يا
حبيبتي قالت لي ما تكملي تعليمك
قلت لها تعليم ايه يا بنتي ده انا بقى
عندي سنه 68 سنه قالت طيب شوفي كده انت
عندك معلومات عامه كثير وانت قارئه جيده
وحتبقي يعني حاجه لو اتعلمت التعليم هيبقى
لك لعبه يعني
فانا سمعت كلامها
بس ما قلتش حاجه جيت بقى من عندنا انا في
المنصوره هي عايشه في القاهره
دنيتي على مديريه التربيه والتعليم وديت
لهم الشهاده القديمه اللي اخذتها سنه 81
دي تنفع اكمل ثانوي قالوا لي ايوه ايوه طب
ده انا من مواليد 43 الشهاده دي
اخذتها سنه 81 قالت له قالوا لي وان كنت
مولوده سنه 1900 احنا عايزينك
شجعوني تشجيع جميل جدا
طب يا تيته دخلت
[موسيقى]
انا كمان عايزه اسالك سؤال لما تحققي حاجه
على عمر 80 دايما بيقولوا لما الانسان
بطول في الشغل عمره بيطول وبضل بكامل نشاط
وبضل شبابه حسيتي هلا بعد ما حصلته
كانك خلقت من جديد زغلطتي 30 سنه مثلا
18 سنه بس
حقك علي
قوي ايوه لان التعليم
وانك بتقري باستمرار
بينشط المخ يا حبيبتي بيمنع الزهايمر
والكلام ده كله وهذا كلام جدا مهم يا تيته
امل عقبال الدكتوراه امال شكرا جزيلا من
القاهره طبعا طبعا شكرا شكرا جزيلا